Disney has produced numerous films you love
and enjoy; that you have probably seen over
and over again.
The Disney animators work on the same scene,
if not same frame for days to make the films
perfect for our delight.
Still, sometimes mistakes fall through the
cracks and these blunders are fun to spot.
Let’s take a look at some of these Disney
oversights and when you see one from your
favorite Disney film don’t forget to subscribe
and join the notification squad for awesome
videos like this one every day.
Here is Screen Rant’s list of ten Mistakes
Disney NEVER Noticed In Their Movies.
The Incredibles
When the Incredibles family and Frozone face
off the new and improved robot provided by
Syndrome, the junior high school Violet gets
her hands on the remote control.
As the kids fumble with the remote to turn
off the robot, Elastigirl takes the remote
and clicks a button that turns off an engine
that Mr. Incredible holds.
Mr. Incredible tells her to press the same
button again and when she presses a button
the engine takes off.
Take a look at the button she pressed, it
was a completely different button.
At least the button didn’t cause the engine
to self explode.
Beauty and the Beast
When the Prince turns away the old lady, she
curses him by turning him into a Beast that
was his big mistake.
The animators of Beauty and the Beast made
a few mistakes themselves during the production
of the Oscar winning film.
In the third act of the film Belle can be
seen wearing a white apron, then in another
scene she can be seen not wearing the apron
but then later on its back on again.
Maybe the apron is cursed like the Beast or
came to life like the clock and candle stick.
Inside Out
When the Anderson family moves to San Francisco,
Riley is not too excited about the big move
they made.
One reason for her hesitation is because her
room is a little scary.
Her first night in her room she sleeps on
the floor and when lights flow across her
room they scare her.
As the lights cross the room, take a look
at the open door.
Then in the next shot when her mom walks into
the room she opens the door.
Maybe Riley had a reason to be scared.
Maybe a scarier from Monsters Inc. made her
a visit.
The Lion King
In the 1994 film, The Lion King the characters
of Timon and Pumba stole the show.
They taught us that hakuna matata means no
worries and that we shouldn’t stress about
the little things in life.
One little thing in life we shouldn’t worry
about is our costumes or at least we learned
that from a scene in The Lion King.
When Timon stands with his back to the camera
we see no lei or flowers but when he turns
around.
Walla!
He has a lei around his neck and flowers in
his hair, that’s an impressive trick Timon.
Frozen
Coronation day is a big day for Queen Elsa
but it seems to be an even bigger day for
Princess Anna.
She’s been locked up in her home for so
long she’s excited to get out and meet people.
As she sings, “For the First Time in Forever”
she imagines herself in paintings that are
around her home.
When she walks through the door look at the
painting on the right side of the frame.
When she jumps from this seat and bounces
into that picture we can’t help to wonder
where that chair came from.
Did she bounce from one room to another room
because there is no chair like that in this
room?
Toy Story 2
It’s common knowledge that if Andy loves
you as a toy he writes his name on the bottom
of your shoe.
This is what all the toys want because it
means you are part of the group.
When Woody is being repaired and cleaned up
by Geri the Cleaner he repaints Woody’s
boot covering Andy’s name.
Later on when Woody is feeling homesick he
rubs off the paint and reveals the name Andy
again.
This time the name is upside down.
Wreck-It Ralph
King Candy is the villain in the film Wreck-It
Ralph and he stops at nothing to stop Venelope
from resetting the game.
Still, like any good Disney film the villain
loses and Venelope saves the day with the
help of Ralph.
Once she crosses the finish line the game
resets and all the markings of King Candy
are supposed to be gone.
Later in the segment when Ralph and Venelope
are talking, King Candy’s logo and face
can be seen at the opening of the track in
the background.
Hercules
After Hercules saves the day with the help
of his sidekick Phil, all the Gods are excited
for them.
One God in particular is Hermes, the Olympian
God of herds and flocks.
He must also be the God of magicians because
when he throws flowers to show his appreciation
of the heroes the flowers are red.
But when Phil catches a flower it is a yellow
flower.
Looks like Hermes is a God of tricks and mischief
as they say.
Zootopia
Nick Wilde is a sly fox and he gets away with
a lot in the film Zootopia.
He tricks Judy numerous times but only once
by having her step into a slab of concrete.
As they talk the concrete hardens and her
feet are stuck in place.
As her feet get stuck she talks to Nick in
one position but when he leaves and turns
back to see her she has turned ninety degrees.
Look at the disappointment on Judy’s face,
even she knows the animators made a mistake.
Tangled
At the end of the film Tangled when Flynn
makes the ultimate sacrifice and cuts Rapunzel’s
hair take a look at his hand as he brushes
her hair.
It is shackle free but in the next shot his
wrist is bound in a shackle and chains.
We know Flynn is a wanted man but we’re
pretty sure he doesn’t know how to escape
from shackles.
Looks like just another mistake Flynn made,
but he ultimately gets the girl so he must
have done something right.
There you have it ten Mistakes Disney NEVER
Noticed In Their Movies.
Don’t forget to subscribe to Screen Rant
for more fun videos.
Thanks for watching.